Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen blicken auf die europäischen Männer Top-Ligen, das heißt Serie A, La Liga und die Premier League. All das wollen wir jetzt hier besprechen in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass 267. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier ist sie wieder, die Ligatur, unser Blick auf die europäischen Top-Ligen. Und ich begrüße diesmal in einer etwas zerstücketen Sendung erst mal nur zwei Gäste bei mir. Haben wir uns auseinander gelebt? Ich weiß es nicht. Also erst mal zu meiner Linken, Christian Bernhard. Schön, dass du hier bist.
Hallihallo, schön, guten Tag.
Und dann uns zugeschaltet, Nils Kern. Hallo, Nils. Was meint ihr, sind wir jetzt wie so eine WG, die zu viel miteinander diskutiert hat und irgendwann trifft man sich nur noch irgendwie, wenn sich zwei Wege im Bad kreuzen oder beim Müll rausbringen?
Ach, der gute alte Dante. Das waren noch Zeiten. Das mit Luce Favre ist ja auch noch mal so eine Geschichte, die vielleicht so ein bisschen untergegangen ist. Weil, ich weiß noch, wir haben am 13. September zum Beispiel über Nizza gesprochen, in der Ligatur von damals. Da hast du ja noch mal erzählt, dass er sich eigentlich mit Lappach schon einig gewesen sein soll und dann von Nizza überzeugt wurde. Und dann ging das jetzt innerhalb von einem Dreivierteljahr so dahin. Wie würdest du denn jetzt seine Zeit da bewerten? Und gibt es denn darüber Erkenntnisse, wie es für Favre jetzt weitergehen könnte?
Ich bin sehr eng mit ihm. Er hat mich mal angerufen vor drei, vier Wochen, als es bei den Bayern sehr schlecht lief, weil wir wissen, was in München los ist. Das war so ein Teamgespräch. Aber dass ich ihn speziell dann frage, was war los mit Nizza? Da kommt natürlich nichts raus.
War das noch vor Tuchel? Also wollte er den Job von Nagelsmann?
Er wollte den Job schon vor einigen Jahren. Weil als Karl-Heinz Rummenigge noch der Präsident war, war er damals bei Serben Gelb als Spieler in Serben Zimmer, wie Kalle, und die haben sich richtig gut verstanden. Ich glaube, wo es damals bei Favres so gut lief, bei Gladbach und bei Slomgen in Hannover, waren beide sogar im Gespräch beim FC Bayern. Und da hat Lülü davon geträumt. Aber als das Angebot von Dortmund kam, dann, wo er noch in Nizza war, beim ersten Nizza-Abenteuer, hat er mir damals die SMS von Waxe gezeigt. Und da hat er sich sehr gefreut, dass Dortmund ihn haben will. Und danach, nach einer halben Jahre, hat er natürlich eine ganz andere Meinung über den BVB, wie es dann liegt mit ihm. Ich glaube, er ist jetzt weit über 60 und merkt immer mehr, wie schwer es ist, mit dem neuen Spielergeneration klarzukommen. Tatsächlich, mit der neuen Mentalität entwickelt sich alles weiter. Und er gehört einfach an eine andere Generation. Ich glaube, das wird ihm auch immer sicherer. Er hat noch nicht ganz abgegeben. Vielleicht reist ihm ein letztes Abenteuer. Aber ich würde auch nicht erstaunt sein oder überrascht sein, wenn wir demnächst die Meldung bekommen, er beendet seine Karriere. Er merkt auch, dass es schwierig ist. Bei Nils wird gesagt, da wurden Versprechungen gegeben, die nie angehalten wurden, von den Vereinserobungen. Da hat man das Problem, dass die Eigentümer aus England, die Neos, die ehemaligen Favres-Ligen noch aktiv sind bei Nizza. Favre hat eine Spielerliste gegeben, die Engländer wollten andere Spieler vorgeben oder eine Liste. Und der, damit nichts anfangen lässt, hat Favre sehr schnell aufgegeben. Und von sich aus nicht dazutreten, er wollte es, klar, aber er hat die ganze Hinrunde mit viel Distanz genommen. Er hat sich nicht mehr so viel Sorgen gemacht, wie man ihn eigentlich kennt. Hatte eigentlich den Kopf schon abgeschaltet und hat nur noch gewartet, dass er entlassen wird. Ich hatte auch mal am Telefon im September, wo es schon hieß, er wird ausgeworfen. Und damals hatte ich schon das Gefühl am Telefon, dass er nicht darauf wartet, aber dass er weiß, dass seine Tage gezählt sind und dass er sich da keine großen Illusionen macht. Also eigentlich war es ein trauriges, gleiche Rende für ihn, weil er tolle Arbeit geleistet hatte bei seinem ersten Abenteuer in Nizza, aber gab es auch sowieso. Aber er hatte einiges mit Kölb, wie er gewinnt ist. Aber irgendwann ist vorbei und ich befürchte, das war es für ihn.
Ich könnte ihn mir sehr gut als TV-Experten vorstellen. Er erklärt ja so gerne Fußball und hat eine sehr nette und sympathische Art. Oder kann er nicht die Trainer-Ausbildung beim DFB noch ein bisschen besser machen? Das könnte doch auch was sein. Ja, schreib es ihm doch einfach mal. Oder ich schreibe ihm die SMS, die zeigt er dir dann aber nicht erfreut, sondern, wer ist denn der Typ? Was soll denn das auf einmal? Also, lose your Fabri, dann schauen wir doch mal. Vielleicht sind ja auch die Härter-Verantwortlichen gerade ein bisschen hellhörig geworden. Mensch, da könnten wir doch auch nochmal eine Geschichte schreiben. Es scheint ja irgendwie alles schon wieder da. Aber das sind andere Themen. Ganz kurz, letzte Frage. Also, jetzt ist ja die Saison so gut wie vorbei. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was du ganz überraschend findest? Ich meine, es gibt ja auch noch das Rennen zwischen Rennes und Lille um den fünften Tabellenplatz. Also der Theorie nach auch noch mit Monaco, aber die sind schon drei Punkte weg bei noch sechs vergebenen Punkten. Aber es gibt ja noch was, was auszuspielen ist, plus der Abstiegskampf.
Monaco spielt in Rennes am Samstag. Okay, siehst du, habe ich gleich gesehen. Weil die Tor-Differenz deutlich schlechter als Rennes ist. Das heißt, wäre ich nicht verwundert, wenn Monaco in Zentralen sechst da ist, und es jetzt ja gar nicht europäisch dabei ist. Die Mannschaft ist gerade auf einem abstandenen Ast mit Trainer Philipp Clément, der auch in Frage gestellt wird. Übrigens posiert der Name Matthias Reis-Lehrer seit heute Morgen am Fürstentum. Und man weiß, dass die Verantwortlichen da immer gerne nach Deutschland chillen. Das haben wir in Kokovac gesehen. Aber das ist etwas wirklich Interessantes bei der Ligue 1-Konferenz am Samstagabend. Was passiert in Monaco, in Rennes. Aber es speckt auch an Lens. Fester zweiter, 2,2 Punkte im Durchschnitt bei diesem 10. Budget der Ligue 1. Eine sehr sympathische Mannschaft. Die Kollegen haben gesagt, es ist die einzige Mannschaft, wo die Spieler auf dem Platz lächeln.
Das sagt auch viel über die ganze Liga aus. Alexi, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Und wir werden uns ja, wenn alles gut geht, dann ja vielleicht sogar in Person in diesem Jahr noch einmal hören zu Ligatür. Also in dieser Saison. In diesem Jahr hoffentlich noch ganz viel. Als der letzte. Genau, sehr gut. Jetzt ist der Druck da. Jetzt kennen die Hörerinnen und Hörer den Aufnahmetermin. Danke dir, Alexi. Bis bald mal wieder. Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier, Uli. Ich freue mich sehr, dich zu hören und dich zu sehen.
Mir geht es genauso.
Das ist doch schön. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich so überraschend, dadurch, dass du hier bist. Und da müssen wir natürlich einmal kurz über den feststehenden Meister sprechen. City hat es geschafft. Und mit was für einem effizienten Ressourceneinsatz, möchte ich sagen.
Ja, es war dann am Ende fast zu erwarten, irgendwie. Clary Neville hat das relativ schön gesagt. Ich glaube, im Januar, am Ende wird City dann doch wieder mit 10 Punkten Vorsprung Meister. Da habe ich nur ein bisschen gelächelt. Aber ja, die sind schon anderswo unterwegs, wenn sie eine normale Form haben. Das, glaube ich, muss man neidlos anerkennen. Da gibt es ja Gründe dafür, die man mal ausgebreitet und diskutiert, mal weniger ausgebreitet, aber rein sportlich betrachtet, wenn das zulässig ist, ist das schon wow.
Ja, und ich meine, da kann auch jeder so seine eigene Meinung haben zu City. Ich habe da eine Meinung, bzw. ich habe da ein Gefühl. Also ich spüre eben, dass ich mich mit City nicht so mitfreue. Und das hängt halt mit dem ganzen Drumherum zusammen. Aber ich glaube, das ist was sehr Subjektives, was wir hier auch schon oft genug thematisiert haben. Was wir uns aber noch nicht besprochen haben, beim letzten Mal, als es nach dem Arsenal-Spiel ja eigentlich auch schon mehr oder weniger fest stand, dass es City werden würde. Ist das ein Problem für die Liga, dass jetzt zum fünften Mal innerhalb von sechs Jahren derselbe Meister, das sind ja fast Bundesliga-Verhältnisse? Und das ist ja das große Schreckgespräch in Europa.
Ja, es wird auch tatsächlich viel diskutiert auf der Insel. Das kenne ich so gar nicht, dass man sich solche Gedanken über die Liga macht, also wirklich so übergeordnete und dann auch langweilige Themen. Weil zumindest war es ja in den letzten Jahren so, dass Liverpool als großer Gegner Cities ganz lange mit dabei war immer, die jetzt aber so aussehen, als gehen sie in eine Art von Rebuild. Und Arsenal traut man es noch nicht so ganz zu, dass die jetzt wirklich der lange Rivale sein könnten. Ich glaube, vorher hat man sich deshalb nicht so richtig viele Gedanken gemacht. Und davor, also bevor Guardiola in die Liga kam, bringen wir es auf den Punkt, gab es das ja nicht. Weil selbst wenn es mal ein 3-Peat gab, es gab schon Manchester United-Zeiten unter Sir Alex Ferguson oder dann auch mal Arsenal kurzzeitig, die so eine leichte Vormachtstellung hatten. Aber sowas gab es noch nie. Und die Engländer haben wirklich große Angst um ihre Liga. Und ich meine, jetzt kann man das Argument nicht bringen, wie in Deutschland, dass das ein Finanzvorsprung ist. Ja, der ist es, minimal, aber natürlich nicht bei weitem in der Größenordnung. Das heißt, wie sollen es denn die anderen machen, wenn City so gut arbeitet? Weil das ist ja das eine. Also die Mittelherkunft, darüber müssen wir sprechen. Auch wenn irgendwann mal am 10. Juni alles gesagt und getan ist und das reichen sollte. Und dann ist es möglicherweise tatsächlich die beste Saison einer englischen Mannschaft ever. Dann muss man speziell über die Mittelherkunft reden, aber den Mitteleinsatz, über den muss man halt auch reden. Der sucht seinesgleichen. Jemals, glaube ich, in der Fußballwelt. Weil was Guardiola nichtsdestotrotz daraus gemacht hat, ist natürlich Wahnsinn.
Ja, und das ist ja auch interessant, weil hier ja die Diskussion so geführt wird. Ohne Investoren kriegen wir nie wieder Spannung. Und jetzt haben wir hier die Investorenliga im Weltfußball. Und da gibt es eben auch Konstellationen, in denen die Spannung weg ist. Vielleicht ist es aber für andere leichter, die Lücke zu schließen. Und das hängt dann mehr von der Verwendung, von dem Einsatz der Mittel ab. Was uns ja vielleicht auch halbwegs elegant zu Newcastle United bringt. Die jetzt die Champions League sicher gemacht haben. Und da muss man glaube ich, bevor man da auch nochmal übers Drum herum spricht, erstmal das sportlich einordnen. Kannst du noch mal kurz ein Bild zeichnen? Es ist ein Bild in vielen Grautönen und jetzt aber sehr viel Farbe, was Newcastle eigentlich so jetzt in den letzten Jahren durchgemacht hat. Grau hast du recht.
Ich bin ja in Weiß und Schwarz. Also es ist, ich glaube, das eine Ding, was wir alle vor Augen haben, ist natürlich der Übernahme-Deal, der auch lange gedauert hat von Saudi-Arabien, damals von Mike Ashley. Und jetzt sind sie in saudi-arabischer Hand, das ist ein Staatsfonds, aber davor war es Mike Ashley, der eine Sportartikel-Verkaufskette hat sozusagen, also einen Discounter, der überall in England ist, inzwischen auch in Deutschland im Übrigen. Und der Typ hatte Newcastle sich aus einem Grund zugelegt, also erstmal zu prallen, ganz, ganz, ganz zu Beginn. Das ist aber dann relativ schnell weggegangen. Dann ging es irgendwann in die Richtung, dass der zum Beispiel den St. James Park mit diesen Namensrechten versehen hat, was überhaupt nicht gut ankam und was dann selbst er gemerkt hat, dass es nicht geht. Und irgendwann hat der nur noch Geld rausgezogen für sich und hat überhaupt gar nichts mehr reingegeben und hat die wirklich fast ausbluten lassen. Also der Verein war, er hat nichts mehr gekauft, er hat einen total verwahrlosten maroden Kader hinterlassen, dann hat er doch mal wieder vereinzelt was reingegeben, damit sie nicht absteigen, hat entsprechende Trainerentscheidungen getroffen und es war wurscht unterm Strich. Also Newcastle hat gar keinen Ausschlag gemacht in die eine oder andere Richtung. Sie sind inzwischen mal abgestiegen. Ja, mein Gott, war halt so. Hat sich auch so ein bisschen der tristen Umgebung, in der der Verein ja reingeboren wurde und diese Region wurde immer trister politisch gesehen. Das heißt, hat sich ganz gut angepasst. Das war irgendwie der Verein der Abgehängten sozusagen. Und das ist, glaube ich, mit auch ein Grund, warum die Menschen jetzt überhaupt gar nicht nachdenken wollen. Die sind überhaupt nicht bereit dazu, die Dimension ihrer Besitzer erkennen zu wollen. Es ist ihnen wurscht, weil endlich wieder jemand sich um die Region schert, endlich wieder Geld reingibt und endlich wieder das Wichtigste, was sie haben, nämlich Newcastle United und den Fußball, florieren lassen und jetzt spielen die Champions League. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Grund, warum das vergleichsweise unkritisch gesehen wird. Also dass jetzt mal in total schneller Raffung erklärt, was da alles passiert ist.
Ja, dazu muss man eben sagen, dass Newcastle immer wieder einzelne Hochphasen hatte, aber eben dieses wir rutschen ins Mittelfeld ab, vielleicht sogar in die 2. Liga und dann kommen wir wieder hoch. Da gab es immer mal wieder aber allein die Träne, die man hatte. Also eine der Hochphasen war unter Kevin Keegan, eine unter Sir Bobby Robson, das ist auch glaube ich die noch, an die sich die Älteren von uns noch erinnern. Das war Anfang der 2000er, wo man eben immer unter den ersten 5 mit dabei war. Dann der Abstieg mit Alan Shearer ja noch, irgendwie so als letzter Kanone, Patrone wollte ich sagen. Und Rafa Benitez war da auch Trainer, aber da haben wir eben schon erlebt, da war ja ein Aufstieg mit dabei und das war ja das Newcastle, was wir jetzt in den letzten 10 Jahren erlebt haben. Irgendwas zwischen Platz 10 und 15 oder vielleicht auch mal ein Abstieg. Und das ist halt jetzt mit der Champions League beendet.
Genau, sie sind wieder da, wo sie damals sozusagen aufgehört haben, als du jetzt begonnen hast. Das ist ja nochmal ein Zeitstrahl 10 Jahre davor gewissermaßen. Und das war ja dann das Hässliche, weil man dachte, mit Mike Ashley kommt jemand, der irgendwie vom Fach ist und der wahrscheinlich ein gewisses Interesse hat, dass Newcastle weiter floriert, um ja auch seine Marke dann zu transportieren. Der hat aber aus rein wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten und rein egomanen Gesichtspunkten gehandelt. Dem ging es niemals um Newcastle United und schon überhaupt kein Stück um die, die den Eintritt da bezahlen fürs Fußballspiel. Und das ist dann sozusagen die neuere Newcastle-Zeit, die sich wahrscheinlich deshalb alleine bei mir so breit gemacht hat, weil die Zeit so lange ging und die war so langweilig. Die war so sterbenslangweilig, weil wir immer wieder das Gleiche erzählt haben. Und immer wieder gesagt, boah, Mike Ashley und niemand hatte irgendwie mehr irgendwas übrig für den Verein, außer die, die ja dafür verantwortlich sind, dass der Verein in der Größenordnung da ist. Nämlich eben die, die Eintritt bezahlen. Und es war eine Zeit lang hands down nichts anderes als Eintritt bezahlen für Newcastle United.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es ein total interessantes Beispiel dafür, sowohl wie die Liga mit ebenso Investoren umgeht und wie dann auch so Investoren sich in den Fußball rein sneaken, trotz Financial Fair Play und so. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht im Detail ausführen. Aber der Fonds, der übernommen hat, gehört ja zu 80% Saudi-Arabien. Und die Liga hat sich durchaus auf dieses Argument zurückgezogen, weil jede Übernahme muss ja überprüft werden. Und gerade im United Kingdom sieht man Saudi-Arabien, glaube ich, rund um die Ermordung des Journalisten, was ja, jetzt habe ich den Namen gerade vergessen, Khashoggi. Glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen kritischer, weil man da direkt mit involviert war. Und das hat die Liga aber dann durchgewunken, hat gesagt, naja, so viel Saudi-Arabien ist das doch gar nicht usw. Ich paraphrasiere jetzt. Und jetzt gibt es eben die Gerüchte, ja, Saudi-Arabien, oder natürlich ein Unternehmen aus Saudi-Arabien soll neuer Hauptsponsor werden. Das ist eben genau der Weg, mit dem man dann eben Financial Fair Play-Regularien einhalten kann, weil man dann eben sagt, ja, Moment mal, wir haben die Kohle ja nicht vom Investor bekommen, sondern von unserem Hauptsponsor, dass der zufällig, wirklich nur rein zufällig mit dem Investor zu tun hat. Das wissen wir ja nicht. Das ist quasi das Manchester City-Modell, das ist das PSG-Modell, das Virtus, das Newcastle-Modell. So funktioniert das trotz Financial Fair Play, dass ein Investor eben reinkommt in einen Verein und dann auch an europäischen Wettbewerben teilnehmen darf.
Die grün-weißen Trikots im Übrigen sind auch. Es hat sich halt ein Designer überlegt, dass das zufällig Saudi-Arabiens Jarts-Farben sind.
Ja, da sehe ich jetzt auch hin. Da wollen wir jetzt auch nicht überkritisch sein. Aber gut, das ist all das. Newcastle hat es auf jeden Fall geschafft, die Champions-League zu machen.
Aber ein Satz vielleicht zum Sportlichen. Das ist potenziell der reichste Club, den es gibt. Ich glaube, da gibt es ja gar keinen Deckel. Also, wenn die wollten, könnten die machen, was sie wollen. Nur zur Ehrenrettung, Eddie House, der ist natürlich auch auf einer anderen Seite ein bisschen problematisch, der will davon halt auch gar nichts wissen. Wird auf der Pressekonferenz immer mal wieder angesprochen. Jetzt hat sich langsam etwas beruhigt, aber es gibt immer mal wieder die Fragen, wenn es dann die originalen El Plasticos gibt. Also das originale Sportswashing-Modell, Chelsea zum Beispiel gegen Newcastle, da ist das ein großes Thema gewesen und eigentlich auch ausschließlich das auf den Pressekonferenzen. Wenn der gefragt wird, will er halt so gar nichts davon wissen, was natürlich immer ein netter Trick ist, sich der ganzen Verantwortung zu entziehen, aber das, was Newcastle seit Übernahme ausgegeben hat für Spielertransfers, das, was dahinter steht, weiß man nur zum Teil, aber auch das hält sich einigermaßen so die Waage zu dem, was für Premier League-Verhältnisse normal ist. Aber was die an Transfers ausgegeben haben seither, könnte sich ein Premier Leagueist mit der Ligenzugehörigkeit in der Dauer wie Newcastle auch so leisten. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nichts, die haben jetzt nicht wie damals Manchester City begonnen, Rubinho zu holen, von Real Madrid und Joe, von Palmeiras für 180.000 Millionen und noch, weiß ich nicht, 20 andere Spieler, die extrem viel groß gekommen sind, die haben wirklich sinnvoll dazugekauft. Und das Fußball-Team als solches macht wirklich Spaß. Es ist gut organisiert, es ist ein sehr physisches. Also der Vergleich, den ich mal bei uns im Podcast genannt habe, zu dem stehe ich und der, glaube ich, fasst ganz gut zusammen. Das ist Liverpool der frühen Kloppzeit. 16, 17, 17, 18. Genau so spielen die. Total unangenehm physisch, wahnsinnig gut eingestellt. Die haben eine Gruppe zusammengestellt von Typen, die ausnahmslos wissen, wann sie ins Pressing gehen, die in dem Punkt wahnsinnig unangenehm sind, die also in erster Linie arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten. Und dann haben sie noch einen Bruno Gimaraes dazu addiert, der das Fußballerische löst. An Joel Linton von Mittelstürmer auf 6 auf 8 umgebaut, funktioniert plötzlich sehr gut. Das ist eine Eddie-How-Sache gewesen. Das muss man denen schon lassen, auch da wieder. Das ist das eine, der ganze Teil, der dahinter steckt. Das andere ist die sportliche Entwicklung. Und Eddie How hat auf 20 übernommen und führt sich in die Champions League innerhalb von 1,5 Jahren. Da ist nicht das ganz große Investment dabei. Vielleicht wäre Regimara es da nicht hingegangen. Kann sein, wenn Saudi-Arabien im Hintergrund nicht gäbe. Vielleicht sind da auch Handgelder geflossen, von denen wir noch nicht wissen. Möglich, aber ich behaupte, so einen Spieler in dem Kaliber, den kann man sich auch mal holen, wenn man einfach 6 Jahre in der Premier League dabei ist. Oder einfach Nothing in Forest ist und es trotzdem macht.
Genau auf die wollte ich jetzt kommen. Das ist super, weil über die will ich nämlich jetzt in dem Zusammenhang auch kurz sprechen. Die haben ja 41 Neuzugänge gehabt. Die haben quasi vom Transfer Saldo her hinter Chelsea und United. Chelsea spielt in der kompletten eigenen Liga, wissen wir auch die Geschichte dazu, United sowieso. Aber dann kommt schon Nottingham Forest, die quasi im Saldo am meisten investiert haben. Und die haben jetzt aber dann doch den Klassenerhalt sicher gemacht. Die sind jetzt safe, 6 Punkte vor Leicester. Es ist ja jetzt nur noch ein Spieltag. Ist da jetzt alles aufgegangen? Ja, es ist ja ein bisschen belächelt worden. Zumindest aus Deutschland heraus, weil da eben auch so mancher deutscher Spieler für viel Geld hingeht.
Ja, und es ist ja tatsächlich so gewesen, dass Steve Cooper im Januar-Fans dann nochmal gesagt hat, bitte nicht so viel machen. Was auch erstaunlich ist für einen Trainer, weil der Besitzer da, Evangelos Malenakis...
Ich bin nicht so gut mit Namen, bitte keine Neuzugänge wäre.
Und der hat immer noch dazu... Also wenn man den jetzt nicht vor Augen hat, dann sollte man sich den parallel mal irgendwie auf einem Endgerät aufrufen. Der hat noch so einen leicht traurigen, in Bayern sagt man mirselsichtigen Gesichtsausdruck. Das heißt, man kann sich das ganz gut vorstellen, wie das wirklich lief, bei dem er das gemacht hat. Also da ist ein Schiffsmagnat aus Griechenland am Ruder, Evangelos Malenakis, der auch Olympiakos besitzt noch. Und der hat schon immer angekündigt in der ganzen Zeit bei Nottingham Forest, ich bring die wieder auf das Niveau damals, wie unter Klaff, und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich die geholt habe. Und wenn wir mal aufgestiegen sind, dann investiere ich mal richtig. Also der hatte, und der hat sich jetzt auch noch mal in einem Interview gezeigt, nach geschafftem Klassenerhalt, nach Sieg gegen Arsenal. Und man merkt, dass der das durchaus auch zu Selbstverwirklichungszwecken macht. Also da steckt jetzt nicht unbedingt ausschließlich eine Kaderbau-Idee dahinter. Wenngleich auch da, das hat auf eine weise Tradition, in den letzten Championship-Jahren war das immer so, dass die immer um die 20 Transfers gemacht haben, rein und so um die 10 raus. Merkt man auch schon, das geht nicht gut auf, wenn man das einfach 6 Jahre lang durchzieht. Die hatten teilweise bis zu 50 Spieler zu Beginn der Saison im Kader, haben ganz oft einen Manager gesucht und jetzt haben sie einen Trainer bekommen. Und das war das größte Glück in der Geschichte des Vereins, dass die Steve Cooper genommen hatten, letztes Jahr dann im Winter aufgestiegen sind und der das irgendwie alles managt. Alleine deshalb, weil es ist ja unmöglich, dass so viele verschiedene Nationen, die allesamt nie in der Premier League gespielt haben, es ist ja kaum einer dabei, von den Neuzugängen, der jemals Premier League gespielt hat. Und wenn man die Liga kennt, weiß man, wie wichtig das ist, dass man sich da einigermaßen einruft. Ist Steve Cooper für mich ein Manager of the Year Kandidat? Also der steht mindestens im Halbfinale, weil das Erstaunliche ist, was der geleistet hat. Das ist kein schöner Fußball gewesen, das war immer das passivste 451, was du dir vorstellen kannst. Aber ich habe jegliches Verständnis dafür, dass er es so macht, weil das ist das Einfachste, was du denen beibringen kannst, das Zentrum zu machen und nicht irgendwie besondere Dinge wollen. Und dann gab es halt ein, zwei Ausreiser nach oben. Ich hatte oft zu vielen, vielen verschiedenen Zeitpunkten echt Angst um die, weil die nicht gut aussahen. Und dann kam aber wieder mal eine Phase von Brandon Johnson, der echt gut aussah. Und dann wieder mal eine Phase von Ryan Yates, witzigerweise die, die nicht neu verpflichtet wurden. Und dann jetzt zum Schluss, morgen gibt es White. Das war ja so der Transfer. Einer, zwei aus der Premier League, aber wo alle gesagt haben, jetzt ist ein kompletter Dachstuhl abgebrannt. Die holen den Ersatzspieler von den Wolverine Wanderers für so viel Geld und was soll das überhaupt? Aber Cooper kannte den zusammen, er ist Joujon-Weltmeister geworden mit ihm und wusste, dass das der Typ ist, der für dieses System wichtig sein wird.
Und so hat es Nottingham tatsächlich geschafft, in der Liga zu bleiben. Und in die Liga hinein möchten zwei Teams, Coventry und Luton, das, wie wird es immer genannt, das teuerste Fußballspiel, also das Spiel, in dem so meisten Geld geht. Wer steigt auf in die Premier League, der bekommt richtig, richtig viel Kohle. Da willst du mit uns noch drauf vorausblicken, denn das ist eigentlich so das Match to watch jetzt.
Das ist das, was Fußball auch kann, auch der moderne Fußballer auch kann. Wir sind in 2023, du sagst schon, richest game of football. Das heißt, wenn das Team, das dann hochkommt, einmal die Klasse hält, haben sie mindestens 300 Millionen Pfund alleine an Fernsehgeldern eingesackt. Da sind wir noch nicht bei Sponsoring und so. Und normalerweise würde man jetzt denken, gut, das treibt alles auf die Spitze, dieses eine Spiel. Das Schöne ist, diesmal sind es zwei Teams gegeneinander, zwei Vereine gegeneinander, die das romantisch machen, auf eine Weise, weil sie es so lange in Anlauf genommen haben, um da dabei zu sein, weil die beiden Teams so viel erlebt haben in ihren Vereinsgeschichten, jetzt auch neuerlich in den Vereinsgeschichten, dass das ein Spiel für die Fans ist tatsächlich. Und ich glaube sogar auch für die Neutralen. Also klar, die Fanlager wissen jeweils, das ist das wichtigste Spiel der Vereinsgeschichte, weil wenn wir das haben, dann werden wir für immer anders dastehen. Aber auch für neutrale Menschen, da gibt es so viele Geschichten. Und ich habe dem im Vorgespräch erzählt, ich habe gestern mit einem Podcaster, Oakheader, drei Stunden telefoniert, der hat mir einfach nur die Vereinsgeschichte Lutentowns erklärt und erzählt. Und was wir gelacht haben, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Vor allem, wenn man die Platzierungen sieht, ehrlich gesagt. Genau, ja, das und dann gibt es aber, nur als Beispiel, da gibt es eine Dokumentation, die kann man sich auch immer noch anschauen. Das ist auch, keine Ahnung, warum die BBC nie dagegen was gemacht hat. Die gibt es bei YouTube. Ich schaue auch gleich nach, wie sie heißt, weil das habe ich natürlich wieder vergessen. Und da kommt einfach ein neuer Besitzer rein bei Lutentown. Und damals, zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als die gemacht wurde, 2001, gab es gerade British Idol, also die Version, Deutschland sucht den Superstar. Und der dachte sich, es wäre doch eigentlich cool, wenn ich mal den Manager so aussuche. Und das ist wirklich aufgezeichnet. Und das ist doch absolute Weltklasse. Das heißt, trouble at the top. Kann man sich tatsächlich immer noch anschauen, halbe Stunde. Was der Typ allein in den ersten zwei Minuten von sich gibt, der Besitzer, ist absolute Weltklasse. Also es ist wirklich, es ist grandios. Ich kannte das nicht, muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen, aber es habe ich mir gleich reingezogen und es ist einfach, es ist unglaublich.
Das ist Looten und was ist zu Coventry noch wichtig zu wissen?
Bei Coventry ist es so, letztes Mal in der Premier League gespielt, auch da muss ich noch mal schnell nachschauen, dass ich jetzt komplett keinen Quatsch erzähle. 2001 und seither so oft abgestiegen mussten, also waren beide Teams, das ist auch nochmal interessant zu wissen, 2017, 18. der vierten Liga gemeinsam, gar nicht so lange her. Und bei Coventry ist es auch so, so oft am Rande der Pleite gestanden. 2012, 2013, kein Stadion gehabt bei Luthen. Die waren dreimal Pleite in zehn Jahren. Und trotzdem ist das Fan-Aufkommen nie weggegangen. Das ist bei Coventry genau das Gleiche. Die haben einen furchtbaren Besitzer gehabt, der jetzt endlich seit Januar weg ist. Also, oder eine Gruppe. Jetzt ist es wieder ein einzelner Businessman. Dann ist aber wiederum lange nicht klar gewesen bis April, wo würden die überhaupt spielen nächste Saison, wenn sie aufsteigen, weil das Stadion in der Hand der Rugby-Mannschaft ist. Die sind aber aus Fußballsicht glücklicherweise pleitegegangen, sodass sie jetzt wieder ihren Stadiondeal haben mussten, zwischenzeitlich umziehen, wie bei Luten im Übrigen auch. Und all diese Dinge, diese superbewegten Vergangenheiten, stehen drüber, über diesen Spielen. Und bei Carpentry ist der Kader, selbst ich muss mit Mühe und Not in meinen Aufzeichnungen gucken, dass ich da irgendwas drüber sagen kann, über die einzelnen Spieler, weil das sind de facto unbekannte Menschen. Bei Luten ist es ein bisschen besser. Also da kenne ich schon ziemlich alle. Ich glaube, da sind auch die meisten Leute, die sich einigermaßen mit Fußball interessieren, werden so fünf, sechs, sieben Namen zusammen bekommen. Bei Carpentry ist das krass, weil es einfach geht nicht. Der Trainer ist seit 2017 da, also hat quasi ganz unten übernommen und hat die jetzt allen Ernstes hochgeführt. Und bei Luten ist es eine ähnliche Geschichte. Die könnten binnen neun Jahren von der fünften in die erste Liga gehen, was beispiellos wäre in der Geschichte des englischen Fußballs. Also, dieses Spiel, wenn dir es nicht packt, dann wurscht, wie viel Geld darüber steht, dann kann ich nichts machen.
Das tut mir leid. Wann findet dieses Spiel statt? Wo kann ich es sehen? Und wer kommentiert es?
Der Reihe nach. Samstag, 17.45 Uhr, hoffe, das stimmt. The Zone und Sebastian Kneißel wird es kommentieren, mit mir zusammen.
Ich dachte, für die drei, die es jetzt noch nicht gecheckt haben, zeige ich es noch mal mit dazu.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig. Es gab eine Diskussion, ob ich das überhaupt noch spielen sollte oder nicht, weil ich eigentlich schon durch bin mit meinen Sachen, die ich so in der Saison machen müsste. Aber da habe ich mich schwer darum beworben, dass ich das gerne machen wollte. Ich hätte es auch so geguckt.
Also Leute, zum Runterkommen, wenn das Saisonfinale in der Bundesliga vorbei ist, könnt ihr euch noch ein bisschen Coventry vs. Luten anschauen. Uli, ich danke dir ganz herzlich für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für eure Geduld. Danke an alle meine vier Gäste, an Alexis Menuge, an Nils Kern, an Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel, habt ihr ja gerade eben gehört. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 267. Bitte unterstützt uns finanziell. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und stöbert mal in unseren Feeds. Da sind so einige Sendungen erschienen und da wird auch noch so einiges passieren in unmittelbarer Zukunft. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.